[Music]
hello there it's fortnite update time
once again let's do what we do and look
at the changes on the island and the
direction of the story a shorter episode
this week i'll explain why very soon
anyway slap code annamaru if you want to
help me pay my bills and let's break
down week 11 of fortnite season 7.
a ton has happened this week including a
brand new game mode which is dripping
with law and storyline you'll see it on
your home screen right away the next
update is to your lobby coral castle has
been decimated by the last reality and
in game we can check for ourselves the
mother ship is once again open and
pulling the location into the air
floating suspended in a tractor beam if
we look at what happened to slurpee we
can guess the next steps as the poi gets
closer to the mothership it will be
transported into it for that mini-game
we play when the abductors work that is
io have rushed over to coral castle and
have set up outposts just like we saw at
the other locations one of which is
right next to the crashed plane which
began chapter two do you remember that
trailer we've come a long way from those
days by the looks of coral the conch
shells will remain so you can still bust
out your tunes whenever you like and
many of the wobbly blobs are staying too
but these two blighters are currently
being dragged into the mothership but
they don't seem to mind chilled till the
end the mothership's actions have
brought over the scientific mastermind
of bill and his dumbass friend ted they
currently sit here on this island stay
with them long enough and they will show
you their new home a couple of tents and
a fire pit what more could they want
when they aren't dancing in sync by the
fire pit they are watching the
mothership with their whiteboard of pure
mathematics well one of them is working
the other is just enjoying a day at the
beach whatever happens next i think we
can safely say the hench bros will be
following it because only these guys and
sloane know what the heck these
equations mean and soon operation bring
down the mothership will happen in-game
where do you think it will crash
over to the most important storyline
change of the season the hashtag
tinychair what a time we've had with
this once huge chair slowly it started
shrinking and last update i thought it
was impossible to go any smaller look at
it it was minuscule i was so wrong
because that epic dev who made this is
on another level to the rest of us not
only is the chair slightly smaller it
now has a teeny tiny teddy bear on top
and a minuscule microscopic telescope
too
it's almost impossible to see it's that
small even at full zoom in replay mode
this may be the greatest thing i've ever
seen in my life hashtag tiny chair so
mythbusters time i grabbed a grabatron
and tried to lift the chair and check
this all three of those items are
completely unique they can be lifted
independently i challenge you to
eliminate someone with a tiny bear and a
tiny chair who will be the first in the
world to get this completely pointless
accomplishments so now you may ask can
it go smaller not a chance right i hope
more items are added around this could
we one day have a miniature fortnite
island on the fortnite island
come on dev i know you're listening you
can do it i have faith in you if this is
the end of the tiny update please take
my thanks epic developer one day i will
know your name and we will all celebrate
it in the comments does anyone know his
name her name their name
a little housekeeping before we go on to
make sure we've covered everything that
was added last week the micro update
brought us free guy into fortnite week
10 was the week we had atm machines that
speak to us using a real world human
being have you finished your challenges
yet i haven't yet because i kind of
quite like having this guy around to
talk to you're taking your time i
respect that approach
okay so the biggest thing of the update
is a whole new game mode it's among us
completely ripped off but no doubting
that but it also has so much charm that
only fortnite can offer and it's a great
game mode to completely ruin your
friendships it links to the story quite
well it stated that agent jones was not
alone when he defected away from io and
someone here is helping him from within
the imagined order and our job is to
find them and kick them out there are
way too many things to cover in this
episode so that's why it's a short one
today i'm going to make a dedicated
video all about these epic details and
secrets in the imposter game mode from
x-men easter eggs to sharks with lasers
on their heads it's gonna be epic right
i'm gonna get straight on with that
video thank you for sticking around
here's a bunch of leggings who used code
adamaru this week thank you for choosing
my code out of all the millions out
there appreciate you see you tomorrow
bye
[Music]
[ __ ]
here
[Music]